there's not much space in a wooden box
but at least she's safe in the corner of
the room this mysterious creature is
called a Pangolin a scaly mammal that is
extremely rare
poachers hunt them for their armor and
their flesh but the vets at this clinic
are trying to keep the species alive
because they're so endangered and and in
such trouble we go through any lengths
to save each one this Pangolin nicknamed
goblin was delivered to the clinic after
a police raid on a smuggling gang and
she was in a terrible condition when she
arrived she's probably about to Kayla
kilos underweight she had a lot of sand
in her stomach
so she'd been eating soon because she
was so hungry right
we weren't hopeful when we got it in the
vets try to build the pangolins up with
tube fed cat food and this here they've
treated dozens of them working with so
many of them I mean we've had how many
we head into Sky News has obtained this
video shot by a trafficker from
Mozambique as he jabs and prods at
Goblin in a paint splattered room the
pictures were taken in November as he
prepared his animal for sale the police
in South Africa have made multiple
arrests but they can't stop the trade
with pangolins now considered the most
trafficked animal on earth in China
their scales fetch tens of thousands of
pounds and the mammals tongue is
treasured as a good luck charm that
makes the business of Pangolin
rehabilitation very stressful indeed but
the vets have to take their patients
like this youthful male called river
outside they simply can't survive
tivity it's a bit like taking the dog
for a walk except this isn't really
about the exercise it's all about the
ants that's what they eat that's their
breakfast their lunch their dinner and
they just can't do this in captivity
they can't feed themselves River is
doing well and in a couple of weeks
conservation specialists will place him
in a top-secret reserve but it won't be
easy to see him go what do you think of
rivers future prospects
unfortunately my it's guarded he's
prognosis wise in the hospital that's
good but survival in a protected reserve
maybe yes but they're healthy enough to
be released but not safe from other
humans back at the Wildlife Hospital
there are other animals to care for
other creatures who've been poached and
trafficked or abandoned it's a serious
crime that's a Pangolin yawn but the
threat faced by pangolins
is different for they are imperiled by
extinction after 80 million years on
earth and the battle to save them is
being waged one creature at a time John
sparks Sky News in South Africa